And I said, well, you know, there's an algorithm for that. There's a lot of algorithms in C++, but not all developers are going to know all of it. We're always on a learning curve. But that whole point of you've probably written almost all the loops you're ever going to need in your life at this point in your career. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 191, recorded on July 11th, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we continue our conversation with Kevlin Henney. In this episode, we talk about multiple programming languages, Fortran, C, Pascal, C++, Python, and python and libraries algorithms and more so for i presume i must have done something in a past life that was terrible and wicked
我说，嗯，你知道，这有个算法。C++里有很多算法，但并非所有开发者都了解全部。我们总是在学习曲线上。但重点是，在你职业生涯的这个阶段，你可能已经写完了这辈子需要写的所有循环。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 191 期，录制于 2024 年 7 月 11 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，继续与 Kevlin Henney 的对话。在这一集中，我们讨论了多种编程语言、Fortran、C、Pascal、C++、Python 以及 Python 库、算法等等。所以我猜我前世一定做了什么可怕而邪恶的事情。
um but i've been but early in my career i am old enough that i've ended up actually you know programming fortran and being paid to do it. Which Fortran dialect was the first one that you worked with? Okay, so the first one I worked with was an extended dialect of Fortran 77. It was not the VAX extensions, which are kind of considered normal. But I was also working with Fortran 66 stuff as well in that company. I was actually taking some legacy that was written in this kind of prehistoric fortran 66 the old the oldest fortran code i've ever had to deal with was fortran 77 and uh right it was fortran 66 was that before they had
嗯，但我职业生涯早期——我年纪够大，以至于我确实最终用 Fortran 编程并以此为生。你最早接触的是哪种 Fortran 方言？好吧，我最早接触的是 Fortran 77 的扩展方言。它不是那种被视为标准的 VAX 扩展。但在那家公司，我也在处理 Fortran 66 的东西。我当时实际上是在处理一些用这种史前 Fortran 66 编写的遗留代码。我处理过的最古老的 Fortran 代码是 Fortran 77，等等，Fortran 66 是在他们有……之前吗？
like the freestyle form was where everything had to be like like 80 characters oh no no no no fortune 66 didn't even let's put it this way it didn't even have else your ifs were all single yeah you know for those of you who are watching this through sound uh connor just like what expression um yeah you had single branch ifs, you had a three-way if. You had the original three-way selection. So for those of you familiar with Stracump, yeah, that's where all this three-way stuff comes from. It comes from Fortran. And you had single branch ifs.
比如自由格式，就是所有东西都必须是 80 个字符之类的。哦不不不，Fortran 66 甚至——我们这么说吧，它甚至没有 else。你的 if 语句全是单分支的。是的，你知道，对于那些通过声音观看的人，Connor 刚才做了一个“什么”的表情。嗯，是的，你有单分支 if，你有三路 if。你有最初的三路选择。所以对于那些熟悉 Stracump 的人来说，是的，所有这些三路选择的东西都源于此。它来自 Fortran。而且你只有单分支 if。
You definitely didn't have loops. Yes, the formatting was fixed. It was in 77. It was not properly until. Wait, you didn't have loops? You didn you had a do loop which is a for loop but you didn't have while loops yeah yeah so you had do loops uh which were basically for loops oh but there was a nice gotcha um a do loop will always execute at least once yeah even if it even if its range is empty it will always execute at least once in other words it's as if somebody wrote what should be a while loop as a do while it will always go through the body once yeah that's a gotcha it also sends a time so interestingly as
你绝对没有循环。是的，格式是固定的。直到 77 才真正……等等，你没有循环？你有 do 循环，也就是 for 循环，但你没有 while 循环。是的，是的，所以你有 do 循环，它们基本上就是 for 循环。哦，但有一个很好的陷阱，do 循环总是至少执行一次。是的，即使它的范围是空的，它也总是至少执行一次。换句话说，就好像有人把本该是 while 循环的东西写成了 do-while，它总是会执行一次循环体。是的，这是一个陷阱。它也发送了一个时间，所以有趣的是……
a result of that experience the first thing even now even though this is like deep in my past even now whenever i look at a piece of code with a loop the first thing i do is not look at what happens when the loop executes the first thing my mind reads is what happens when this doesn't execute and you have no idea how many bugs i found that way the first thing i do is what happens when this executes zero times because normally when people are writing loops your mental model is i'm dealing with lots of stuff okay you know i am sorting things i am arranging things i am reading things in i am sending things out your default is oh our application
作为那次经历的结果，即使是现在，尽管这已经是我过去很久的事情了，即使是现在，每当我看到一段带有循环的代码时，我做的第一件事不是看循环执行时会发生什么，我大脑读取的第一件事是当它不执行时会发生什么。你无法想象我通过这种方式发现了多少 bug。我做的第一件事是：当它执行零次时会发生什么？因为通常当人们写循环时，你的思维模型是“我在处理很多东西”，好吧，你知道，我在排序，我在整理，我在读入，我在输出。你的默认设置是“哦，我们的应用程序……”
deals with much stuff it deals with millions of stuff it deals with giga stuff you're thinking in the many but you've got to remember zero is in there as well so so many cases fall over on the empty it's like every time i write a function that takes a size parameter, I think about like, hmm, the first thing I want to do when I write this function is think about what do I do when size is zero? Yeah, yeah. And that kind of sensitivity there is just like, so my brain is kind of fine tuned to that. But I, and funny enough, the first job i ever did where i was using fortran we were not using we were not doing it for scientific programming or anything that required that kind of efficiency uh if you like its historical sweet spot uh we're actually doing
处理很多东西，它处理数百万个东西，它处理千兆级的东西。你在考虑“多”，但你必须记住“零”也在其中。所以很多情况在空集上会崩溃。就像每次我写一个带有 size 参数的函数时，我都会想，嗯，我写这个函数时想做的第一件事就是考虑当 size 为零时我该怎么办？是的，是的。那种敏感度就像……所以我的大脑对这一点进行了微调。但，有趣的是，我做过的第一份使用 Fortran 的工作，我们并不是在做科学编程或任何需要那种效率的事情——如果你喜欢它历史上的最佳应用场景的话——我们实际上是在做……
systems programming um this is also the same company exactly you know when people say the right tool for the right job yeah this is what is what taught me the value of at least part of that expression. We don't always know our full toolkit. Did you say citizens programming? No, no, no, not citizens, systems. Systems programming. I don't know. Yeah, the whole citizen thing, that's later.
系统编程。嗯，这也是同一家公司。确实，你知道，当人们说“合适的工具做合适的工作”时，是的，这就是教会我这句话至少一部分价值的东西。我们并不总是了解我们完整的工具包。你说的是“公民（citizens）”编程吗？不，不，不，不是公民，是系统（systems）。系统编程。我不知道。是的，整个公民的事情，那是后来的事了。
Okay, yeah, that's a misunderstanding. But even so, I would say 4chan is uniquely unsuited to systems programming. And I remember when... Why would it have been selected for systems programming? Something you said. Familiarity. Because that was the language the boss who set up the company knew. So what's the first thing you do?
好吧，是的，那是个误解。但即便如此，我会说 Fortran 在系统编程方面是极其不合适的。我记得当……为什么它会被选为系统编程语言？你刚才说了一些话。熟悉度。因为那是建立公司的老板所知道的语言。所以你做的第一件事是什么？
You use the thing you know, don't you? Even if it's uniquely unsuited. What sort of platform was this on? Oh, this was back in the days when there were mini computers. So this was a data general. And we also did stuff on PCs. And we were transitioning to PCs at that point. But somebody, some bright spark, had the idea that we should learn C.
你用你熟悉的东西，不是吗？即使它极其不合适。这是在什么样的平台上？哦，那是在小型机时代。所以这是一个 Data General。我们也在 PC 上做东西。那时我们正在向 PC 过渡。但有人，某个聪明人，有了个主意，说我们应该学习 C。
And the sensation of learning C was like stopping hitting your head against a wall. It's just like suddenly realize, oh, yeah, with Fortran, I've been wrestling with all these concepts that were not present in the language. And suddenly I learned C. It's just like, well, this is easy. This is absolutely, I can say what I want. You know, linked lists, trivial. Dynamic memory management, done. Oh, it's even got proper control flow structures and I don't have to worry about dialects. Because C has one normalized. so we're talking about culture one of the normalizing
学习 C 的感觉就像停止用头撞墙。就像突然意识到，哦，是的，用 Fortran，我一直在与所有语言中不存在的概念作斗争。突然我学会了 C。就像，嗯，这太简单了。这绝对是，我可以随心所欲地表达。你知道，链表，小菜一碟。动态内存管理，搞定。哦，它甚至有合适的控制流结构，我不用担心方言问题。因为 C 有一种标准化的……所以我们谈论的是文化，其中一种标准化的……
aspects of c um originally was the value of portability the idea of a standard the idea that that's actually a first class value although fortran did by that point have a standard. It did, but the point is that what had happened is that Fortran had splintered. And that's why there was a call for a standard. It had splintered. So the motivation in that standard was actually originally quite different. And we still had dialects. People would be sitting there going like, yeah, it's Fortran 77 subset. We're using VAX.
C 的方面，嗯，最初是可移植性的价值，标准的理念，这个理念实际上是一个一流的价值，尽管 Fortran 到那时已经有了一个标准。确实有，但重点是 Fortran 已经分裂了。这就是为什么会有对标准的需求。它分裂了。所以那个标准背后的动机实际上最初是非常不同的。我们仍然有方言。人们会坐在那里说，是的，这是 Fortran 77 子集。我们正在使用 VAX。
And so therefore it was a de facto standard that kind of helped drive. It's funny because this is still true today. If you look at modern Fortran compilers, there's not really any that implements everything. Like, even just now we're starting to see them implement all of like fortran 2008 but there's things like caray fortran that only a few compilers support and it's like it's still very in a way dialecty yeah it's and and that notion of portability it's an idea that is now if you like become very normal in younger languages, was not part of the value system. And we also see it with historical languages like Pascal. And a lot of people, you get a lot of people saying, you know, a particular generation,
因此，它是一个事实上的标准，在某种程度上推动了它。很有趣，因为这在今天仍然适用。如果你看看现代 Fortran 编译器，没有哪一个真正实现了所有功能。比如，即使是现在，我们才开始看到它们实现所有 Fortran 2008 的功能，但还有像 Coarray Fortran 这样的东西，只有少数编译器支持，这就像它仍然非常“方言化”。是的，那种可移植性的概念，是一个现在如果你喜欢的话已经变得非常正常的理念，在年轻语言中，并不是价值体系的一部分。我们也从 Pascal 这样的历史语言中看到了这一点。很多人，你会遇到很多人说，你知道，特定的一代，
when they were taught Pascal at university, was their first language to go, oh, yeah, yeah, I really like Pascal. Scratch the surface and you'll find that if they actually programmed in what was standard Pascal, they would have hated it because it was just like, yeah, what it turns out, a lot of people say,
当他们在大学里学习 Pascal 时，那是他们的第一门语言，他们会说，哦，是的，是的，我真的很喜欢 Pascal。但深入挖掘一下，你会发现如果他们真的用标准 Pascal 编程，他们会讨厌它，因为它就像……是的，事实证明，很多人说，
oh, I really like Pascal. And then you scratch the surface. It's like, actually, it's object Pascal. It's Delphi. It's this. It's this extended. Pascal is one of the most extended languages historically.
哦，我真的很喜欢 Pascal。然后你深入挖掘。就像，实际上，它是 Object Pascal。它是 Delphi。它是这个。它是那个扩展。Pascal 在历史上是最容易被扩展的语言之一。
Academics used to love extending it. The number of papers I used to love extending it the number of papers i used to read through it's just like oh here's another extended pascal it's just like you just it's a very different way of thinking now these days with languages we've taken a very the philosophy that c came came along so like when people sat around extending c you kind of look at them going like being really cautious it's just just like, are you sure? This feels very abnormal. And only a couple of C extensions have ever escaped into the wild
学者们过去很喜欢扩展它。我过去读过的论文数量……我过去很喜欢扩展它，我读过的论文数量，就像，哦，这是另一个扩展的 Pascal。这就像，你只是……这是一种非常不同的思维方式。现在，对于语言，我们采取了一种非常……C 出现时的哲学，所以当人们坐下来扩展 C 时，你会看着他们，表现得非常谨慎，就像，你确定吗？这感觉非常不正常。而且只有少数几个 C 扩展曾经流传到野外，
with any kind of popularity, one of them being C++, the other one being Objective-C, which is now on the decline. As a result of, we were talking about Swift earlier, as a result of that, because there was only one company really championing it. But that notion there is that one company really championing uh but that that
并获得了一定的流行度，其中一个是 C++，另一个是 Objective-C，现在正在衰落。结果是，我们之前谈到了 Swift，结果是，因为只有一家公司真正支持它。但那个概念是，一家公司真正支持……但那个……
notion there is that extensions are viewed with some suspicion um and uh you know there's there's occasion you get oh well you know here's kind of like a built-in magical keyword on this platform that does something very pragmarish and so but it's very light dusting rather than oh yeah it's the core of the language that you're actually messing with. And so C++ has inherited that idea that, yeah, there is a, of itself, this is a value. And other languages have different foundation concepts and those are rather nice and standard. There is the idea of like, what other versions of rust or python you know there's a couple of variations of python by platform but people again are a little bit suspicious if you step too far from what is considered the core that's just like yeah okay i can see what you're doing there but you
那个概念是，扩展被视为有些可疑。嗯，而且……你知道，有时你会得到，哦，好吧，你知道，这里有一个内置的神奇关键字，在这个平台上做一些非常像 pragma 的事情，所以这只是轻微的修饰，而不是“哦，是的，这是你正在修改的语言核心”。所以 C++ 继承了那个理念，即“它本身就是一种价值”。而其他语言有不同的基础概念，那些相当不错且标准。有类似“Rust 或 Python 的其他版本是什么”的想法，你知道，按平台划分的 Python 有几种变体，但人们再次对你偏离被视为核心的东西太远感到有点怀疑，那就像“是的，好吧，我能看出你在做什么，但……”
know come back to the center come back to the light um it's a very different value whereas in fortran it's just like yeah this is the way we do it and whatever the the value system is very very different but curiously enough we're so we're romping across the ground here let's let's actually try and find the road again because the reason i mentioned fortran is i work the other job i did not systems programming actually did involve doing um actual computation um proper number crunching it was uh modeling um modeling a system of water flow so i used to work in the water i worked in the water industry and i then worked in the electricity industry and hindsight suggests that you don't want to mix electricity and water so you know
你知道，回到中心，回到光明。嗯，这是一种非常不同的价值。而在 Fortran 中，就像“是的，这就是我们做事的方式”，无论价值体系是什么，都非常非常不同。但有趣的是，我们在这里跨越了这么多领域，让我们试着重新找到方向，因为我提到 Fortran 的原因是，我做的另一份工作，不是系统编程，实际上确实涉及进行……实际的计算，真正的数字运算。它是……建模，模拟一个水流系统。所以我过去在水务行业工作，然后我在电力行业工作。事后看来，你不应该把电力和水混合在一起，所以你知道……
but water flow through what so uh a water network distribution network so reservoirs your house the pipes outside your house that kind of stuff, pumping stations and this kind of stuff. So this is a water modeling network. And the idea is one of the things we want to do was model the propagation of some waste into a river upstream. How does that affect the reservoir? And how does that affect what goes out of the houses? So, you know, how does this dilute and thin out over time? Where do we end up with concentrations and so on? So very interesting problem at that level. So I was working on this kind of code. It was built onto an existing system. And so therefore, we were dealing with legacy code already. But the person I was working with, she was a mathematical modeler.
但水流过什么？所以，一个水网，配水网。所以水库、你的房子、你房子外面的管道之类的东西，泵站之类的。所以这是一个水建模网络。这个想法是，我们想做的事情之一是模拟某种废物向上游河流的传播。这如何影响水库？它如何影响从房子里流出的东西？所以，你知道，这随着时间的推移是如何稀释和变薄的？我们最终在哪里得到浓度等等？所以在这个层面上是一个非常有趣的问题。所以我当时在处理这种代码。它是建立在现有系统之上的。因此，我们已经在处理遗留代码了。但我一起工作的那个同事，她是一位数学建模师。
The only language she'd ever learned at that time was Fortran. So when she's writing out the specifications, so she's sitting there going like, okay, how do I turn partial differential equations into something that can be coded up? Her worldview is immediately shaped and solely shaped by her programming language experience, which is Fortran. So I ended up, when I remember reading this, I remember reading her specification, you know, her requirements document, and my code ended up being shorter than the requirements document because her pseudocode was huge because it was
当时她唯一学过的语言是 Fortran。所以当她写规范时，她坐在那里说，好吧，我如何将偏微分方程转化为可以编码的东西？她的世界观立即被她的编程语言经验所塑造，且完全被其塑造，那就是 Fortran。所以我记得读到这个的时候，我记得读她的规范，你知道，她的需求文档，我的代码最终比需求文档还要短，因为她的伪代码太庞大了，因为它是……
written in this very, very procedural style of Fortran. So the point that she was, oh yeah, you need to initialize, you've got a two-dimensional, you've, she said, oh, yeah, you need to initialize. You know, you've got a two-dimensional matrix. You know, you've got a 2D matrix. So you need to initialize that. So she would write rather than, you know, the value of pseudocode is you can say what you want. Nobody's going to compile it. You say, I've got a matrix. Set every element to zero.
用这种非常、非常过程化的 Fortran 风格编写的。所以她的观点是，哦，是的，你需要初始化，你有一个二维的，你……她说，哦，是的，你需要初始化。你知道，你有一个二维矩阵。你知道，你有一个 2D 矩阵。所以你需要初始化它。所以她会写，而不是……你知道，伪代码的价值在于你可以说你想说的。没人会编译它。你说，我有一个矩阵。将每个元素设为零。
Or set every element to whatever value you want. No, she would set up a nested for loop or nested for loop and initialize everything to zero. So what could be said in just a few words and one line was now five lines um and yeah so there was this expansion from what you could say so that idea of like here's something i can say very directly and very simply so going back to your point yeah you can write you know we can write incomprehensible code in any medium. You can write some crazy comprehensions. You can write comprehensions that wander off the right-hand side of the screen in search of the horizon and never stop and are just treacherous.
或者将每个元素设为你想要的任何值。不，她会设置一个嵌套的 for 循环，将所有东西初始化为零。所以本来可以用几句话和一行代码说清楚的事情，现在变成了五行。嗯，是的，所以从你能说的东西中出现了这种扩展。所以那个想法，就像“这里有一些我可以非常直接和简单地说出来的东西”。所以回到你的观点，是的，你可以写，你知道，我们可以在任何媒介中写出难以理解的代码。你可以写一些疯狂的推导式。你可以写出那些为了寻找地平线而偏离屏幕右侧、永不停止且极其危险的推导式。
But the point is that for some of the simple stuff is you just want to say, I'm done with this. I don't need to set up a loop and append things and do work. And I feel the same as well when I look at some C++. And funnily enough, something I was looking at just last week, I was running a workshop for a company and it was somebody had gone through a very long process and saying, and I said, well, you know,
但重点是，对于一些简单的事情，你只是想说，我做完了。我不需要设置一个循环并附加东西并做工作。当我看到一些 C++ 时，我也感觉一样。有趣的是，就在上周，我为一家公司举办了一个研讨会，有人经历了一个非常漫长的过程，我说，嗯，你知道，
there's an algorithm for that. You know, there's a lot of algorithms in C++, but so, you know, not all developers are going to know all of it. you know there's a lot of algorithms in c++ but so you know not all developers are going to know all of it we're always on a learning curve but that whole point of you've probably written almost all the loops you're ever going to need in your life at this point in your career you've written a loop that does everything does one thing to everything you've written the loop that searches for a thing. You've written, after a few months of programming, you've probably written all the shapes of loops
这有个算法。你知道，C++ 里有很多算法，但所以，你知道，并非所有开发者都了解全部。你知道 C++ 里有很多算法，但所以，你知道，并非所有开发者都了解全部。我们总是在学习曲线上。但重点是，在你职业生涯的这个阶段，你可能已经写完了这辈子需要写的所有循环。你写过对所有东西做一件事的循环，你写过搜索某物的循环。在编程几个月后，你可能已经写完了所有形状的循环，
you're ever going to need. What you want is somebody to commodify that and say, it's okay, I've got the loop handling. You just plug in the bits that I need to do. Yeah, all the loop management's done in the background. We've got this, you know, this is fine. Just tell me over what you want this done and the thing you want done
你这辈子需要的。你想要的是有人能将其商品化，并说，没关系，我已经处理好循环了。你只需要插入我需要做的部分。是的，所有的循环管理都在后台完成。我们有这个，你知道，这很好。只要告诉我你想对什么执行此操作，以及你想做的事情，
or the value you would like to do. And that idea, I think, is a really important one that sometimes a language feature will help us, but sometimes it is a library or the support there to say, you know what, we've already seen this. Everybody's seen this a thousand times. And most legacy code, there are lots of reasons code becomes legacy and treacherous. But a lot of it, one of the things you can always guarantee is that, almost without fail, is that when you look at something that somebody's called legacy, you see control flow. You see a lot of control flow. You don't say, this is legacy because it's compact. It's not that it's so compact it's unreadable.
或者你想做的值。我认为这个想法非常重要，有时语言特性会帮助我们，但有时是库或支持，说，你知道吗，我们已经见过这个了。每个人都见过这个一千次了。大多数遗留代码，代码变得遗留和危险的原因有很多。但很多时候，你可以保证的一件事是，几乎毫无例外，当你看到别人称之为“遗留”的东西时，你会看到控制流。你看到大量的控制流。你不会说，这代码是遗留的，因为它很紧凑。并不是因为它太紧凑而无法阅读。
It's actually mostly spread out. I'd say that there's kind of almost a 10 to 1 ratio, and I'm really making the numbers up here, but there's more of an extreme. You're getting the sense that most legacy code is characterized by lots of stuff making decisions about things. Oh, I'm going to if on this. I'm going to while on that. I'm going to switch on the other thing. And I'm going to record a condition, and I'm going to put it in a ball. Then I'm going to come back to that later. And then I'm going to if on this, I'm going to while on that, I'm going to switch on the other thing. And I'm going to record a condition and I'm going to put it in a ball, then I'm going to come back to that later. And then I'm going to do something else. And I'm going to revisit the ball later. And then we're going to change, you're changing flags and read it. And that it just grows, it just it just continues growing. And that's one of the things you open up, you open up a code base, it's just like, yep, lots of control flow. And I'm not saying
它实际上大多是分散的。我会说有一种大约 10 比 1 的比例，我真的是在编数字，但有一种更极端的倾向。你会感觉到大多数遗留代码的特征是大量的东西在对事物做决定。哦，我要在这个上面 if。我要在那个上面 while。我要在另一个上面 switch。我要记录一个条件，我要把它放在一个球里。然后我稍后再回来处理它。然后我要在这个上面 if，我要在那个上面 while，我要在另一个上面 switch。我要记录一个条件，我要把它放在一个球里，然后我稍后再回来处理它。然后我要做别的事情。然后我稍后再重新访问那个球。然后我们要改变，你在改变标志并读取它。它只是在增长，它只是在不断增长。这就是你打开的东西，你打开一个代码库，就像，是的，大量的控制流。我不是说……
you don't want any control flow. But I'm saying if that's the main feature that strikes you, it's just like, yeah, there's probably some of this stuff that's been done before and lives in a library, or that if it doesn't live in the library, then think of yourself as the library builder. Yeah, we do this all the way through the code. Oh, commodify it, factor it out. What can I use? Can I use a class? Can I use a function? Is there templating opportunity here? Could I just extract this and you toss me a lambda and we're all good? What is the bit that I can pull out? Either because somebody else has done it in a library that is standard, that is available,
你不需要任何控制流。但我想说的是，如果这是让你印象最深刻的主要特征，那就像，是的，可能其中一些东西以前已经做过了，并且存在于库中，或者如果它不在库中，那么就把自己当作库构建者。是的，我们在整个代码中都这样做。哦，商品化它，提取它。我能用什么？我能用一个类吗？我能用一个函数吗？这里有模板化的机会吗？我能直接提取这个，你给我一个 lambda，我们就都好了吗？我能提取出什么部分？要么是因为别人已经在标准库中做过了，要么是因为我们可以自己做，因为它在我们的代码中是一种如此常见的形状，也许我们应该把它提取出来。我认为这就是我试图鼓励人们去思考的方式，但默认情况下我们不会，我们总是使用我们拥有的原始工具，这通常正如你所说，非常命令式。是的，这很有趣，因为我实际上……我前几天在写一个 Python 列表推导式，我需要做一个笛卡尔积，一个多维笛卡尔积。我需要一个从 0 到 n 的整数元组，在所有不同的维度中。当我写的时候，我在想，像一个比我更了解 Python 的人，肯定有一些函数我可以调用，我可以只在推导式中调用 1, 4, 4，它就给我返回一个元组的可迭代对象。肯定有人写过这个，但我不知道谁，这个东西叫什么，我不知道做这件事的正确方法是什么。
or because we can do it ourselves because it's such a common shape in our code that perhaps we should pull that one out. And I think that's the thing that I'm trying to encourage people to think like that but by default we don't we always work with the raw tools that that we have which is often as you say very imperative yeah it's interesting because i i actually uh i was writing a python list comprehension the other day uh where i i needed to do a cartesian product a multi-dimensional cartesian product i needed like a tuple of like integers from zero to n in all the different uh dimensions and and as i was writing i was thinking like somebody who knows python
（接上）
better than me there surely must be some function i can call where i can just call like 1, 4, 4 in the comprehension and it gives me back an iterable of tuples somebody must have written this but I don't know who, what this thing would be called I don't know what the proper way to do this is
所以我只会写 `for k in range(0, n): for j in range(0, n):`。这看起来很易读。但我认为人们进入一门他们不了解文化的语言时可能会遇到的问题是，你不知道这些模式是怎么拼写的。就像你有时甚至不知道，我该去哪里找这些东西？比如常见的做事方式。而且它在不同的语言之间往往是不同的。
so I'll just write 4k in range 0 and 4j in range 0N, 4J in range 0N. And like it's pretty readable. But I think one of the problems that people may have coming into a language where they don't know the culture is you don't know what these patterns are spelled. Like you don't, sometimes you don't even know, like where would I go to find these things? Like the common ways of doing things. And it tends to be different from language to language.
（接上）
Yeah. In fact, that might be the, that's also one of the issues going back to this idea of like core culture or received culture is sometimes these things aren't common but they were put there with intention in other words you know it's it we you know so we might say you know standard library the stl i mean stl when was that kind of introduced 1994 okay that that was kind of uh um steppenhoff and lee that's when i think when they made their proposal originally to the committee. So 30 years ago. And we'd like to say that that's common. I don't think it's necessarily common if I look across a lot of C++ code bases. It's more common in some companies,
是的。事实上，这可能是……这也是回到这个“核心文化”或“既定文化”理念的问题之一，有时这些东西并不常见，但它们被放入其中是有意图的。换句话说，你知道，我们可能会说，标准库，STL，我的意思是 STL 是什么时候引入的？1994 年。好的，那是……Stepanov 和 Lee，我想那是他们最初向委员会提交提案的时候。所以是 30 年前。我们想说那是常见的。如果我查看很多 C++ 代码库，我不认为它一定是常见的。它在某些公司、
in some groups, but it's been available for a long time and it was put there with intention. And the problem is that people sometimes don't recognize that that's there, particularly the larger a language and its library gets, the harder it is to accidentally stumble across something or to even know to ask the right question. And that is an issue. I was running a workshop for a company a few months ago and actually it was basically, it was Python and it was Python. And it was Python-based. And although the workshop wasn't, hey, here's Python, I spent a lot of time saying, oh, you know you can write this more compactly. You know, there's a thing in Python for this. There's a thing in that.
某些团队中更常见，但它已经存在很长时间了，而且它是带着意图被放入其中的。问题是人们有时没有意识到它的存在，特别是语言及其库变得越大，偶然发现某些东西或甚至知道问正确的问题就越难。这是一个问题。几个月前我为一家公司举办了一个研讨会，实际上它基本上是 Python。它是基于 Python 的。虽然研讨会的主题不是“嘿，这是 Python”，但我花了很多时间说，哦，你知道你可以更紧凑地写这个。你知道，Python 里有这个东西。那个里有那个东西。
And that's simply because my experience has been different to their experience. But I kind of look for this. Whenever you look into a language, you kind of, there's kind of a thing you want to say, probably somebody's already done this and solved it and it should be there in an era where we don't, you know, so going back to one of the key differences, so Fortran and C versus, so we're talking about standardization. I think one of the interesting differences between, say, the Fortran and C side of things and the C++ and non-ISO languages, say, Java, Python, and so on, there the standard is library, half the standard is language.
这仅仅是因为我的经验与他们的经验不同。但我会寻找这个。每当你研究一门语言时，你都会有一种想法，可能有人已经做过并解决了这个问题，它应该在那里。在一个我们不……所以回到关键区别之一，Fortran 和 C 与……所以我们谈论的是标准化。我认为 Fortran 和 C 方面与 C++ 和非 ISO 语言（比如 Java、Python 等）之间的一个有趣区别是，那里标准就是库，标准的一半是语言。
I haven't actually looked in terms of page numbers and certainly not in terms of printouts, because I think that would be forest destroying for C++23. But what proportion would you say of the C++23 standard is library? So I actually know the answer to this. Excellent. I was hoping. Let's say it's, I think C++20 was, I think 23 was like 2,200 pages. I don't know what it's going to be for 26. But out of those 2,200 pages, like 800 pages were language and the rest was library okay so we are almost at the
我实际上并没有从页数方面看过，当然也没有从打印件方面看过，因为我认为对于 C++23 来说那会是森林毁灭。但你认为 C++23 标准中库的比例是多少？我实际上知道这个答案。太棒了。我正希望如此。假设它是……我认为 C++20 是……我认为 23 大约是 2200 页。我不知道 26 会是多少。但在那 2200 页中，大约 800 页是语言，其余的是库。好的，所以我们几乎到了……
point where that it's important to note that that the way that the library section is uh structured um we the way that we specify like library functions in the standard we have all this like front matter where we say like you know like we have this returns clause that means this, and we have this equivalent to that means this. Whereas in the language, so basically there's a template for stamping out the library definitions. If you wrote it out for the language itself, we don't really do that because there isn't as much of a uniform shape of things for the language. So if you didn't templatify how you specify the library it would
这一点很重要，即库部分的结构方式。我们指定标准库函数的方式，我们有所有这些前言，我们说，你知道，我们有这个“返回”子句，这意味着这个，我们有这个“等同于”，这意味着那个。而在语言中，基本上有一个用于印制库定义的模板。如果你为语言本身写出来，我们并没有真正这样做，因为语言没有那么多统一的形状。所以如果你不把指定库的方式模板化，它……
probably be a good bit longer yes and i i think i i agree with you that because i remember because i was a i was a member of the standard uh old standard stuff just pre just pre 98 and uh member of the bsi panel on that and it was really interesting when the stl came in because the stl had kind of introduced this slightly more compact and let's pull out front matter and you know here's the things everything has in common to stop us doing this repetition whereas prior to that everything had been specified very much the way the c standard does which is and there's no there's no effective templating as it were much more long form and and that was the the language was very minimal very very very small whereas c++ i was saying actually the
可能会长得多。是的，我同意你的看法，因为我记得，因为我曾是标准……旧标准成员，就在 98 之前，是 BSI 小组的成员。当 STL 进来时，这真的很有趣，因为 STL 引入了这种稍微紧凑一点的东西，让我们提取前言，你知道，这里是所有东西共同拥有的东西，以阻止我们做这种重复。而在那之前，一切都是按照 C 标准的方式指定的，即没有有效的模板，形式更长。而且语言非常极简，非常非常小。而 C++ 我当时说，实际上……
language is going to be bigger and then that became very definite with c++ 11 it was like c++ 98 was putting it was just like move it was halfway between these two worlds but c++ 11 onwards has been like oh no no no we library's a thing it's a really important thing it's a separate um you know it's a very it's it's that's where a lot of the value lies whereas historically been oh it's it's about the language and the library is almost an appendix it was it's actually you know the whole the whole value structure is like flipped on its head and then we look at other languages you know python a standard python distribution i have no idea how many modules there are it's just like there's there's just
语言会变得更大，然后这在 C++11 中变得非常明确。就像 C++98 处于这两个世界之间，但 C++11 之后就像“哦不不不，库是一回事，它是一件非常重要的事情，它是一个单独的……你知道，它就是……这就是很多价值所在”。而历史上一直是“哦，它是关于语言的，库几乎是一个附录”。它实际上是……你知道，整个价值结构就像被颠倒了。然后我们看看其他语言，你知道，Python，一个标准的 Python 发行版，我不知道有多少模块。它只是……有……
loads of stuff and that's what people get like what even who even like cares what the line between like like what's standard in python and what's just like a pip package that you can install, like it's very blurry. Like what even is standard? Like in my sector of Python, like NumPy is like standard. Like, you know, everybody uses NumPy. You can just, if it's like something in NumPy, like it's no big deal to depend upon it. It's just such a different bar than C++
很多东西。这就是人们得到的，比如，甚至谁在乎 Python 中什么是标准的，什么只是你可以安装的 pip 包？这非常模糊。什么是标准的？就像在我的 Python 领域，NumPy 就像是标准的。就像，你知道，每个人都用 NumPy。你可以只……如果它是 NumPy 里的东西，依赖它没什么大不了的。这与 C++ 的门槛非常不同，
because in Python, like Python has a packaging story and has its shit together with regards to dependencies. Well, OK, they have their own problems, but more so than C++. They have a different class of problems than C++. Yeah, and the point is they have a different class of problems because the shape of the tooling and the history and the culture of language, what they value and what they want is going to be different. And the point you make about pip, I think, is important because it allows you to blur the line a little bit between de facto standards, something that is agreed on by a body, so the Python Foundation, who, you know, rub a stamp and say, yeah, we've agreed this.
因为在 Python 中，Python 有一个打包故事，并且在依赖关系方面处理得很好。好吧，他们有自己的问题，但比 C++ 好。他们有不同于 C++ 的问题类别。是的，重点是他们有不同类别的问题，因为工具的形状、历史和语言文化，他们所重视和想要的东西是不同的。关于 pip 的观点，我认为很重要，因为它允许你稍微模糊事实上的标准（由机构同意的东西，比如 Python 基金会，他们盖章说，是的，我们同意这个）之间的界限。
Here's, you know, we have a PEP number for this and all the rest of it. And the, you know, sort of the de jure standard and the de facto standard, which is this is what people use. You know, the de jure is like we have decreed this is the case. De facto, everybody's doing it this way. And we see that for the fact that Python comes with actually two unit testing modules that are considered standard. Unit test, which I generally always caution people away from, and doc test, which actually most people don't even know exists. And the majority of people in the larger Python world, typically,
这里有，你知道，我们为此有一个 PEP 编号等等。以及，你知道，某种法律上的标准和事实上的标准，也就是人们使用的方式。你知道，法律上就像我们已经颁布了这种情况。事实上，每个人都以这种方式做事。我们看到 Python 实际上带有两个被认为是标准的单元测试模块。Unit test，我通常总是告诫人们不要使用它，以及 Doc test，实际上大多数人甚至不知道它的存在。而在更大的 Python 世界中，大多数人，通常……
the standard is PyTest. And that's because of... I was just about to say, I've heard of neither of those because the projects that I'm familiar with just use PyTest. Yeah, and that blurred line between the de jure, what has been decreed as standard
标准是 PyTest。那是因为……我正要说，我都没听说过那两个，因为我熟悉的那些项目只用 PyTest。是的，法律上的标准与……之间那条模糊的界限。
and what is normal as standard. And actually that's the way that some libraries made their way into the core Python distribution. Because, oh, look, everybody seems to be relying on this and using this all the time. Why don't we just redraw the boundary line? And aren't there also two standard argument parsing things? There's like op-pars and then argument.
什么是正常的标准。实际上，这就是一些库进入 Python 核心发行版的方式。因为，哦，看，每个人似乎都在依赖这个并一直使用它。我们为什么不重新划定边界线呢？而且难道没有两个标准的参数解析东西吗？有像 optparse，然后是 argparse。
Yeah. Yeah, they're going to let them do what they want. It's just like, let's have a fight, see who wins. Or we'll have both. So the notion there is very different. And so nobody's going to sit down and document the whole of Python, except over time, python.org will aggregate this stuff. The system within C++ is very, very different. But that recognition of, oh, the library is where,
是的。是的，他们会让他们做他们想做的事。这就像，让我们打一架，看看谁赢。或者我们两个都要。所以那里的概念非常不同。所以没有人会坐下来记录整个 Python，除了随着时间的推移，python.org 会聚合这些东西。C++ 中的系统非常、非常不同。但那种认识，哦，库是……
the library is a lot of where the value is, is something that any new language immediately, any new kid on the block has to accept that. You've either got to say, I'm a new language and I'm really cool. What do you integrate with? We integrate with nothing. Oh, show me your standard libraries. They're kind of minimal. Okay. minimal okay well you know i think it's an interesting intellectual exercise but that's not going to make any impact um yeah and you have to have either one or both of those uh attributes you've got to come along and say i'm a new language and i'm building on top of this i integrate really well with this language this environment this ecosystem whatever it is or you say i come with all these goodies and these will solve your problems. These are your problem-shaped goodies. This is what I'm
库是很多价值所在，是任何新语言必须立即接受的事情。任何新来的家伙都必须接受这一点。你要么得说，我是一门新语言，我真的很酷。你和什么集成？我们什么都不集成。哦，给我看看你的标准库。它们有点极简。好的，极简，好的，嗯，你知道，我认为这是一个有趣的智力练习，但这不会产生任何影响。嗯，是的，你必须拥有这两个属性中的一个或两个。你必须走过来，说我是一门新语言，我建立在这个之上，我与这门语言、这个环境、这个生态系统集成得非常好，无论它是什么。或者你说，我带着所有这些好东西来，这些将解决你的问题。这些是你的问题形状的好东西。这就是我……
offering you. It's not just the language. I'm offering you a bit of ecosystem, which libraries all the way through to build systems and package managers. That's where the value lies. That's what people want to, what people now look for in a language so although they say i am using language language x what they actually mean is yeah that's they're talking about the tip of the iceberg there they want the rest of the iceberg and that's what they expect and i think that's what sometimes people find frustrating when they move from one language to another that has is radically different historically so if you grew up with python or um you know if you grew up with Python, or, you know, if you grew up with Python, or you've grown up in the.NET sphere,
提供给你的。不仅仅是语言。我提供给你一点生态系统，从库一直到构建系统和包管理器。这就是价值所在。这就是人们现在在语言中寻找的东西。所以虽然他们说我正在使用语言 X，但他们实际的意思是，是的，他们在谈论冰山一角。他们想要冰山的其余部分，这就是他们所期望的。我认为这就是人们在从一门语言转移到另一门在历史上截然不同的语言时有时会感到沮丧的原因。所以如果你是在 Python 中长大的，或者……你知道，如果你是在 Python 中长大的，或者你是在 .NET 领域长大的，
working with C Sharp, Microsoft Tools,.NET, and all these integrations, these are normal. Or you've got used to package managers like Pit, and then you suddenly come into C++, it's just like, you know, there isn't quite that, I think would be an understatement. And you kind of go, okay um you know what am i looking at oh we've got a really cool language and there's some library and then we look at the
使用 C#、微软工具、.NET 和所有这些集成，这些都是正常的。或者你已经习惯了像 pip 这样的包管理器，然后你突然进入 C++，这就像，你知道，没有那种东西，我认为这会是一种轻描淡写。你有点像，好的，嗯，你知道我在看什么？哦，我们有一门非常酷的语言，还有一些库，然后我们看看……
library and go there's a lot going on here um and that's where a lot of the value is but we still find a few gaps missing that have become normal in other languages but are still um from an outsider's point of view oh why isn't that in C++? Don't we all do this? Don't we all have UI needs and networking needs and so on? And these have been relatively late arriving. So outsiders arriving in, it's just like, oh, okay. And you're telling me about Boost and other things. Oh, what's the standard package manager for that?
库，然后说这里有很多事情发生。嗯，这就是很多价值所在，但我们仍然发现了一些缺失的空白，这些空白在其他语言中已经变得正常，但仍然……从局外人的角度来看，哦，为什么 C++ 里没有这个？我们不都这样做吗？我们不都有 UI 需求和网络需求等等吗？这些来得相对较晚。所以局外人进来，就像，哦，好的。你在告诉我关于 Boost 和其他东西。哦，那里的标准包管理器是什么？
So people stumble across- Have you heard of CMake, another language? First, go learn that. then we can talk about yeah yeah you know the the that that whole that whole idea of like yeah almost embarrassed and there's almost a hesitation when people say cmake it's just like oh okay this is the dirty secret can i buy you a drink we'll have a conversation to private. To be fair, if you're going to, like, yeah, CMake has its problems, but, like, Python setup tools has its problems, too. Like, I was trying to do, like, to change some part of how, like, you know, this Python package I was working on, like, built. And, like, you know, it was as painful as it would have been to learn how to do something in CMake. And then, like, when I was starting, you know, to do some Python stuff and I wanted to patch a thing in, like, I tried to do something with, like, one of the libraries at the company.
所以人们偶然发现……你听说过 CMake 吗，另一门语言？首先，去学那个。然后我们可以谈谈。是的，是的，你知道，那个……那个关于“是的，几乎很尴尬”的想法，当人们说 CMake 时，几乎有一种犹豫，就像，哦，好的，这是肮脏的秘密，我能请你喝一杯吗？我们私下谈谈。公平地说，如果你要……就像，是的，CMake 有它的问题，但 Python setup tools 也有它的问题。就像，我试图做一些改变，比如，你知道，我正在处理的这个 Python 包是如何构建的。而且，你知道，这和学习如何在 CMake 中做某事一样痛苦。然后，就像，当我开始，你知道，做一些 Python 东西时，我想在里面打个补丁，比如，我尝试用公司的一个库做一些事情。
And I was trying to patch a thing in that library. And so I was trying to set up a development environment. I know that there's this conda stuff and then there's this whole virtual environment ecosystem in Python. And then there's all these things, all these words that I'd heard. And I was like, oh, this sounds complicated. And so I asked the main maintainer of this, I'm like, hey, look, like I've just been like – like what I've been doing is I just like – I created like a virtual environment like using this like the simplest – the thing that seemed like the simplest thing and it's like kind of kludgy but it seems like it does what I want. Like do I need to go like learn these other things? And he was like, look, like other people may tell you differently. But like I think what you're doing is like fine because it's like a simple way for like somebody who's new to the ecosystem to get started and like then you don't have to
我当时正试图给那个库打个补丁，所以我想搭建一个开发环境。我知道有 conda 之类的东西，还有 Python 整个虚拟环境生态系统。我听过很多相关的词汇，当时觉得这听起来很复杂。于是我问了该库的主要维护者，我说：“嘿，你看，我一直以来的做法就是——我创建了一个虚拟环境，用的是那种看起来最简单的方法，虽然有点笨拙，但似乎能满足我的需求。我还需要去学习那些别的东西吗？”他回答说：“你看，别人可能会有不同的建议，但我认为你现在的做法没问题，因为对于刚接触这个生态系统的人来说，这是一种简单的入门方式，而且这样你就不必……”
learn like what conda is what anaconda is why there's a snake here um but just like there even in a language that has a good like package ecosystem like python like there is like a lot of stuff there i will say like you know it was pretty easy for me to get like up and running um but like i i run on like a debian system um and like if i try to like pip install something on that system like it pip yells at me it's like hey whoa like you should have installed that with like debian packaging and so then like then there's that whole clash between if you have an OS package manager and then you also have a language package manager. I think that the ecosystem is still a lot better than C++ because the one thing that was relatively painless was once I figured out how to properly use the package management system, like it took a little bit of time to figure out how to create the development environment and
“去学习什么是 conda，什么是 Anaconda，为什么这里会有条蛇。嗯，但即使是在像 Python 这样拥有良好包生态系统的语言中，也确实有很多东西。” 我想说的是，对我来说上手其实挺容易的。不过，我是在 Debian 系统上运行的，如果我尝试在系统上用 pip 安装东西，pip 就会对我大喊大叫，说：“嘿，等等，你应该用 Debian 的包管理工具来安装。”所以，如果你同时拥有操作系统包管理器和语言包管理器，就会产生这种冲突。我认为 Python 的生态系统仍然比 C++ 好得多，因为一旦我弄清楚了如何正确使用包管理系统，事情就变得相对轻松了。虽然花了一点时间才搞明白如何创建开发环境和……
use the package management system. But then once I'd done that, like getting the dependencies was just like very easy. Whereas in C++, if I had to start working on some new C++ project that had like five dependencies, then I'd have to go and build one of them. And like one of them would have like, you know, like a build tools script. And like one of them like just wouldn't build on my system. And it would just be it would just be a whole thing. It would be a whole day thing to get set up. The problem is, Bryce, is you're comparing C++ is lack of a package management like cohesive or comprehensive one to pythons which like python was created in the 90s i don't know when their package manager
使用包管理系统，但一旦做到了，获取依赖项就变得非常容易。而在 C++ 中，如果我必须开始处理一个有五个依赖项的新项目，我就得去构建其中一个，而其中一个可能还会有构建工具脚本，甚至有一个可能在我的系统上根本无法构建。这会变成一件大麻烦，得花上一整天才能搞定。问题在于，Bryce，你是在拿 C++ 缺乏一个有凝聚力或全面的包管理系统，去和 Python 做比较，而 Python 是在 90 年代创建的，我不知道他们的包管理器……
and pip showed up but like this is a solved problem now like you're comparing a language that doesn't have a solution to a language that has a bad solution rust swift go like name a modern language this is a solved problem okay but but um but people use python i know but like we're sitting here comparing two bad things saying like oh you know we shouldn't give c++ such a bad time because python's not that great either but um but rust doesn't have the install base that python has so like like I'm, Python is another language that is exists and deploys
和 pip 是什么时候出现的，但这在现在已经是一个被解决的问题了。你是在拿一个没有解决方案的语言，和一个有糟糕解决方案的语言做比较。Rust、Swift、Go，随便举个现代语言的例子，这都是已经解决的问题。好吧，但是……人们确实在使用 Python。我知道，但我们坐在这里比较两个糟糕的东西，说：“哦，你知道，我们不应该对 C++ 太苛刻，因为 Python 也没那么好。”但是，Rust 的安装基础没有 Python 那么大，所以……Python 是另一种存在并部署的语言。
at the scale of a Java or C++. And like, like the reason that I'm doing stuff in Python and not in Rust
其规模达到了 Java 或 C++ 的水平。我之所以在 Python 而不是 Rust 中做这些事情……
and Swift and other things, they're all great languages. But the reason I'm doing stuff in Python is because like, we have a lot of users who want to do things in python because people use python and so like because like yeah it's like an old established thing and like it's crufty but like it's cruft
以及 Swift 和其他语言，它们都是很棒的语言。但我之所以在 Python 中做这些，是因为我们有很多用户想用 Python 做事，因为人们都在用 Python。所以，是的，它是一个古老且成熟的东西，虽然有点陈旧，但这种陈旧……
it's crufty because people use it right yeah yeah you can have you can have the perfect language that nobody uses or you can have something right yeah you not going to you're the the i think the the debate when we come down to these things um is normally we're always looking for perfection and i think actually we should just be comparing degrees of imperfection i think it's a much more honest way of doing it it's like what kind of imperfections does this have because it's going to have them and the question is do they get in the way? So Python has accumulated imperfections. I mean, it's been around since 1990. That was its first release. So, you know, it's quite an old language.
之所以陈旧是因为人们在使用它，对吧？是的，你可以拥有一种没人使用的完美语言，或者你可以拥有某种……对，你不会……我认为当我们讨论这些事情时，通常我们总是在追求完美，但我认为实际上我们应该只比较不完美的程度。我认为这是一种更诚实的方式。就像是“这种东西有什么样的缺陷？”，因为它肯定会有缺陷，问题是它们是否会阻碍你？所以 Python 积累了一些缺陷。毕竟它从 1990 年就开始存在了，那是它的第一个版本。所以，你知道，它是一门相当古老的语言。
You know, it's... Slightly older than me. It's pre-grunge, you know. It's a 90s kid, you know. So, yeah, basically, Python is a millennial. So there we go. I've recently started classifying languages according to human generations.
你知道，它……比我稍微大一点。它是在垃圾摇滚（grunge）之前出现的，你知道的。它是 90 年代的产物。所以，是的，基本上 Python 是个千禧一代。就是这样。我最近开始根据人类世代来对编程语言进行分类。
So Python's a millennial, but it's one of the older ones. But that means it's been around a lot. It has accumulated. It's going to accumulate a lot of craft. It doesn't have, it's not going to be perfect in any way, shape or form, and therefore we know that of any language but c++ is imperfect in different ways and the idea now again is that idea of if we think about
所以 Python 是千禧一代，但它是比较老的那一批。这意味着它存在了很久，积累了很多陈旧的东西。它不可能在任何方面都完美，我们知道任何语言都是如此，但 C++ 的不完美之处在于不同的方面。现在的想法又是，如果我们考虑……
it and pick up on connor's point it's just like it's a solved problem if you were to introduce a language now and you said we're not going to address these things, people kind of look at you and go, oh, it's a research language then. You know, these are things that people would expect as normal, but they would forgive for an older language. We were talking about Fortran earlier on. I have no idea what these things are in the Fortran space. Is it a solved problem? Because you look at Rust, which has great package management ecosystem, but as Rust starts to grow,
并接上 Connor 的观点，这只是一个已解决的问题。如果你现在要引入一门新语言，却说我们不打算解决这些问题，人们会看着你说：“哦，那这是一门研究型语言。”你知道，这些是人们认为理所当然的事情，但对于一门古老的语言，他们会选择原谅。我们之前谈到了 Fortran。我不知道 Fortran 领域里这些东西是什么情况。这是一个已解决的问题吗？因为你看看 Rust，它有很棒的包管理生态系统，但随着 Rust 开始增长……
we start to see pain points, like building like Rust things, lots of dependencies because everything gets built from source can take a lot of time. And because Rust's model is like everything needs to be built from source, when you have like
我们开始看到痛点，比如构建 Rust 项目时，由于所有东西都是从源码构建的，大量的依赖项可能会花费很长时间。而且因为 Rust 的模型是所有东西都需要从源码构建，当你拥有……
closed source things in the ecosystem like it's not so clear how those integrate and like if you look at 10 years down the road i think rust is clearly going to be a top five language um but by the time it gets to that point for all we know rust's package management ecosystem could look as as complex and grungy as a python i don't i don't know i disagree isn't isn't building from source like orthogonal to package management uh my my point is is just that um as Rust grows in scale, and it will over the course of the next 10 years, I think, grow in scale by an order of magnitude, it will take on new use cases, and as it grows in age, it will take on legacy. And that, you know, like over time, that will lead to additional complexity. It's inevitable.
生态系统中的闭源东西时，它们如何集成就不那么明确了。如果你展望十年后，我认为 Rust 显然会成为前五大语言之一。但等到那时，谁知道呢，Rust 的包管理生态系统可能看起来和 Python 一样复杂且陈旧。我不确定。我不同意。从源码构建难道不应该独立于包管理吗？我的观点只是，随着 Rust 的规模增长，我认为在未来十年内它会增长一个数量级，它将承担新的用例，随着它年龄的增长，它也会背负历史包袱。而且，你知道，随着时间的推移，这会导致额外的复杂性。这是不可避免的。
Yeah, it'll certainly become potentially cruftier rather than rustier. But it is a case of... There's that Henny wit. There is a difference there in the sense sense and going back to the idea of idea these things are solved problems but it doesn't mean that everything is trivial it just means oh yeah somebody has done this and our challenge is is you know what what are we going to do about it and how are we going to make this standard now the thing is the rust foundation is the is effectively the the
是的，它肯定会变得更陈旧而不是更“生锈”（rustier）。但这确实是一个……这就是那个 Henny Wit 的梗。这里确实有区别，回到这些问题是已解决的问题这一观点，但这并不意味着一切都是微不足道的，它只是意味着“哦，是的，有人已经做过这件事了”，而我们的挑战是，你知道，我们要对此做些什么，以及我们如何使之成为标准。现在的问题是，Rust 基金会实际上是……
clearinghouse for this kind of stuff so whatever solution we see we we are able to transport ourselves in time see see what happens 10 years in the future and for those of you who are listening in um 2034 let us know um but whatever happens in the future the chances are that it will have been done in a way that again it won't be perfect because the language goals and its and its users will have shifted but it is likely to have been explicitly addressed and probably in a way that's a bit tidier than well you know we were just talking about python it's probably going to learn from that in other words they have the benefit you know future us it's just like it's one of those classic things you've always got to remember about being forgiving about legacy code is a case of like well whoever was writing this probably was doing the best they could they didn't
这类事情的结算中心。所以无论我们看到什么解决方案，我们都能够穿越时空，看看十年后会发生什么。对于正在收听的各位，在 2034 年，请告诉我们结果。但无论未来发生什么，它很可能以一种并非完美的方式完成，因为语言的目标及其用户已经发生了变化，但它很可能会被明确地解决，而且可能比我们刚才谈论的 Python 要整洁一些。换句话说，他们有借鉴的优势。你知道，未来的我们，这就像是关于宽容遗留代码的经典案例之一：无论谁在写这些代码，他们可能都在尽力而为，他们没有……
have your knowledge because guess what you've seen this stuff you've got some other benefit you've already the problems they were initially struggling with were perhaps new to them and you've got this gift of time and you have a position you have an ability to use it so the the point there is that you couldn't build a perfect package managed back in 1990 because it wasn't even recognized as a thing as a problem so in 10 years time they've got the experience of the last quarter century, for example, to build on. So it won't be perfect, but it's probably going to be, you know, halfway decent at least. And agreed upon. I think that's the other thing. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links
你的知识，因为猜猜怎么着？你已经见过这些东西了，你有一些其他的优势。他们最初挣扎的问题对他们来说可能是全新的，而你拥有时间的馈赠，你有能力去利用它。所以重点在于，你无法在 1990 年构建一个完美的包管理系统，因为当时它甚至没有被认为是一个问题。所以在十年后，他们拥有了过去四分之一个世纪的经验作为基础。所以它不会是完美的，但至少可能会是相当不错的，而且是大家达成共识的。我认为这是另一回事。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中，还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取……
to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢这期节目，祝你有愉快的一天。低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是“充满信息碎片的混乱”。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。